[Music]
you're always so well-dressed we got a
lot of young guests you know you're a
gentleman come on the show and they got
t-shirts and they're like deal with it
dude I mean come on yeah you let you let
John Draper going on here you you
flatter me sir no I actually it's so
funny that you say that cuz I actually
when I was a kid before I became an
actor in Iowa I did a little bit of
modeling you modeled as a kid here's the
deal like there's no outlet for acting
in Iowa so my mother who thought it
would be fun for me to do commercials
she's like I'll put him in some kind of
modeling school and maybe that will sort
of segue into acting somehow so as a
result of it I actually did real
modeling work like I did some some print
work and then I did like I've walked a
catwalk at like a I'm all for your
runway the old were you when you walk
the catwalk I think I was like six or
five or six
it's just chirping yeah you're a segment
producer actually I was talking to him
about this and I have a photo and I'd
say photo this is you modeling it to the
agent to me six or seven or simplify
[Applause]
oh look at you got the turnover the
sheet there yeah incredible
that's a little mystery
that's incredible well you know I
learned that either like what what is
what is imprinted into my mind at that
age to do that yeah there's no fashion
channel like what's the reference point
innate awesomeness yeah you're just born
awesome you do it you just knew it you
know then Kanye it's funny Brent this
photo because you have very you have
hardcore fans you've got great fans and
a lot of them now and of course people
online get very creative but they're
doctoring photos of you for some reason
they all want to turn you into a woman
okay
and I don't know if you want have you
looked at any of these I'm not let's
take a look that's what we're here for
there you are yes No
and let's see the next one please I'm
just Charlie I'm just curious I don't
know how many oh okay that's let's put
that one away pretty [ __ ] is yes I
want to get a copy that last one
I hope you're okay with ash I love that
they didn't really take any pains to
remove the facial hair if you go back to
the first one it's super like he's
beardy
he's beauty's beardy she's beardy well
who can yeah let me ask you a quick
question
you you spent I mentioned in your in
your credits up front all the work
you've done with the Tolkien you know
the The Hobbit and all the work that
you've done with the trilogy and you
spent all that time in New Zealand that
was just curious what did you pick up
you don't have any accent or anything
but you've spent a chunk of your life in
New Zealand shooting these films did you
pick up anything from it did I pick up
anything from I don't know just like any
of their lingo did you pick up anything
and New Zealand why oh yeah like um they
say a thing called Bob's your uncle
mm-hmm which effectively is just like in
affirmative and they also they also say
how does your uncle means yes yeah cuz
I've heard yeah I think I've got it I've
got it Bob's your uncle I don't
understand cause that's not your say it
Sally's your aunt Sally's your in it if
you want to carry on right so if you ask
me a question that was yes like you know
were you born a redhead and I'd be like
Bob's your uncle yeah yeah it would be
so weird in that context there's another
one we're not here to eff spiders yeah
so we're not going to do that what are
we here for
I mean literally here's a great say
fantastic Peter Jackson would say that
like you know we're right in the thick
of something everyone's focused the
energy is you know towards the scene and
we're not here to F spiders we're here
to shoot this shot I'm gonna use that
I'm gonna use that all the time at
rehearsal come on cut to a spider oh
darn it
[Laughter]